[ YouTube Learning ]
Now let’s have a look at how you can upload
your pre-recorded videos to your YouTube channel.
Let’s go!
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
On YouTube, you will always see this
PLUS button around the top right region.
When you click on it,
you will be given two options.
To upload a video; or to go live!
In this video, we will only concentrate on
how to upload videos.
So, click on the Upload video link
which will bring you to this screen!
YouTube is now asking you to select
The video files that you want to upload.
And yes, you can upload more than
one video at once.
Let’s try uploading a video now!
You can click on the Select Files button,
select the video you wish to upload, and then
click on Open.
The uploading process has now begun,
and you will see the name of the
video file you uploaded here!
The progress bar at the bottom tells you what
percentage of your video has been uploaded.
After the video is uploaded, YouTube will
take a few seconds to process it,
and then you will see
the ‘Finished Processing’ sign.
At this point, you’re ready to
add the details about your video.
The first step is to add a title and
a description of your video.
They should both be short, crisp
and must also include important keywords.
Having good titles and descriptions will
not only help your viewers but will also help
you with Google search rankings,
more watch time, and more subscribers.
Yes, good titles and descriptions will
help your channel grow significantly.
The top part should always contain
the actual description of your video.
And then you could add your school website link,
or your youtube channel subscription
link, and so on.
So the description box is not just about
the description of your video, but a lot more.
Another important aspect of the video that
many people overlook on YouTube
is the ‘Custom Thumbnail’ option.
What’s a thumbnail?
A thumbnail is an image you upload along with your that helps your viewers understand
what your video is all about, with a
glance.
You can also call it a marketing image for your video.
You will get to upload a custom thumbnail
only after your account is verified in good standing.
We will see how to do that in the upcoming videos.
You are also expected to
truthfully answer these questions here.
If your content is made for kids,
then you need to select this option.
This helps YouTube
create a safer environment for children.
If your content is not made for kids,
select the 2nd option here, and here as well.
You should know that YouTube has specific definitions
for the term “Made for Kids”
To know more about it,
check out the link in the description below.
Let’s mark it as ‘Made for kids’ here.
You can also click on ‘More Options’
and fill in more details about your video.
You should especially focus on the Tags section.
Add all the important
tag words related to your video.
These tags could be something
that many students search for.
You could also then select the Education category here.
So what next?
Clicking on ‘Next’ will lead you to the
Video Elements page.
These are additional overlays you can use
on your video to lead your viewers to your other videos.
And then we come to the last stage of Visibility
which gives you four options.
If you keep it public, then anybody who visits YouTube
could watch your video.
If your video is unlisted, then only people
with your video, link will be able to watch
your video and nobody will be able to find
it just by searching on youtube.
And if you keep it private, then you could share
it with specific people only by adding their Gmail IDs.
To understand this better, take a moment
to pause this video, and check out this table.
But many times, we don’t want to publish
the videos immediately.
So YouTube also gives us this option to
SCHEDULE our video.
For now, let’s keep it public.
With this, your video is now uploaded,
and ready to reach the world.
You could also then go to the My channel option on the
top right corner, and you will see
a video under the Videos tab here.
So now you know how you can upload your videos to
your YouTube channel.
The next session will be very interesting!
I will talk about how you can go LIVE on YouTube!
See you there.
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]